Speaker 1: Sarah Palin is running for a House
of Representatives seat representing Alaska.
She's the former mayor of Wasilla, the former
partial term governor of Alaska and former vice
presidential running mate back in 2008. You might
remember she quit being governor before the end of
her term and she is essentially giving up. And
if I didn't think she was such a disaster for
the country, I might feel a little bit bad for
her, but I don't. Sarah Palin appeared on Steve
Bannon's The War Room, and she said there, you
know what, I'm no longer accepting donations. I've
gotten rid of my campaign staff, staff because
they gave me bad advice. Let me interpret this
for you. Sarah Palin has given up. She's trying to
save money because it would be pointless to keep
spending money because she's obviously going to
lose. But look at the spin. I didn't know what way
was up and down after I heard this the first time.
Speaker 3: I'm going to get in trouble for saying
this. But sometimes you wonder the people who
are actually advising, working on campaigns.
You got to wonder if they're really in it for
the right reasons, because sometimes they give
really crappy advice and effort. So I'm doing a
lot of this myself. I'm not going to ask people
for donations, though, which ticks off those in
my campaign who and other campaigns, you know,
because they look at this as a business and
they get a cut of funds raised. I don't ask
people for money because I've won all the races
that I've been in over my life except one,
the big one, and I've done it being outspent
10 to 1 or whatever it is, because, you know.
Speaker 1: She'll be outspent 10 to 0.
Speaker 3: Now, our role and
it's always worked well.
Speaker 1: Yeah. And you can
tell from the look on Steve Bannon's face, it's
over for Sarah Palin. What this means is nobody
is supporting me anymore. I'm out of money. No
one's donating anyway. So I'll say I'm no longer
accepting donations, as we talked about last week.
Republican Alaska Senator Lisa murkowski is voting
for Sarah Palin's Democratic opponent. People
don't like that Sarah Palin quit being governor.
A lot of Republicans in Alaska don't like Sarah
Palin. And this is just the last nail in the
coffin. I'm no longer having any staff and I'm
no longer accepting donations. You're giving up,
Sarah. You're giving up. And my hope is
and I don't know if this will be the case.
My hope is that this will really be the end
of Sarah Palin's political career, a career
that never really should have gotten started.
But it did. And she is really in a in a sense,
a precursor to the Trumpism that exists today.
Palin giving up and it is yet another humiliation.